hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
whole bunch of people talking about Rey
in the new films that she might be led
to the dark side of the force there's
some evidence for that so I'm going to
explain what's going on you may have
also heard that Lucas song came out and
said that there are no plans for a
digital Leia in Star Wars Episode nine
so that's huge news I wanted to mention
that too but there is a new round of the
Star Wars giveaway it's to IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything so number seven the force isn't
something you read about in a text book
the Jedi Temple was destroyed along with
the library there are probably a few
textbooks that talk about the Jedi and
the force around the Church of the four
still exist so people probably stole
things and hid them but usually the
force is something that force sensitive
people just come to on their own unless
they're trained by a master and now that
there is no Jedi Order
there was an awakening like the force
sort of awakened in Rey a lot of people
have theories about it awakening at
other characters until Luke starts
teaching Rey and telling her the way of
things she's really just left to her own
devices to make her own choices so
everyone's born with infinite potential
for good and evil that's why the Jedi
would select new candidates for the
academy when they were very very young
before they have time to form their own
opinions about the world so that the
Jedi could mold them like lumps of clay
teach them the way of things so that
they didn't get confused by things that
would lead them to the dark side of the
force so number six jedi dogma had a
very specific way of defining what was
good what was evil very rigid rules
about what your behavior should be they
had the rule that you weren't allowed to
get married weren't allowed to have
children because that would lead to
emotions that might lead you to the dark
side of the force
fear is the path of the dark side fear
leads to anger anger leads to hate hate
leads to suffering the dark side of the
force that's how things played out with
Anakin Skywalker fear led him to make
the choices that he made and that's why
Yoda was reluctant to continue Luke
Skywalkers training because he's too old
he had all these opinions he had friends
that he was afraid to lose so the big
test during Empire was you know whether
or not he would let that fear control
him and lead him to the dark side of the
force but he was definitely touched by
the dark side of the force in that movie
so number 5 Luke Skywalker tempted by
the dark side of the force
multiple times the cave scene is the
best example of that it's a place that's
very strong in the dark side of the
force it shows him this very meta vision
of what might happen and it also reveals
some of the truth about himself before
Darth Vader had actually revealed that
he was his father he didn't know that
Darth Vader was his father when he went
into that cave but basically what the
force vision showed him is that would he
go down the dark side of the path and
make the wrong choice this is the fate
that awaited him he would take his
father's place at the Emperor's side but
it also showed him that he could
literally become Darth Vader because
Darth Vader was his father like he was
like literally wearing the Darth Vader
costume it's a great example of how they
can reveal a whole lot of information
about characters in their future without
literally telling it to you on screen so
just think about that when you're
rewatching Rey's force vision like she
hears all these voices sees a lot of
things that the lightsaber saw but it
also reveals truths about what might
happen in the future so number 4 Mark
Hamill himself even said that in the
original Star Wars Episode 4 script that
they shot there was a bunch of scenes at
tashi station that got cut out showing
you more about who Luke Skywalker was
before he met the other heroes and just
how open he was to any new perspective
any new idea he was so ready to get off
of Tatooine that he didn't even think of
the Empire's evil he had absolutely no
political leanings whatsoever wasn't
thinking about the genocide they were
committing all the stuff that we saw
during rogue one
so I played this Mark Hamill clip and
then just think about how evil Luke
might have become had things gone a
little differently it's inferred that I
become my head in the clouds and I'm a
dreamer and all this stuff and nothing
that I think is really interesting as
Garrick Hagen plays Biggs Darklighter
he's the only one of the
let's see one two three four actors that
wasn't completely cut out he's in the
assault image F star at the end but he's
in this imperial outfit and I'm like wow
cool you know so and clearly I have no
political persuasion it's like you're a
Nazi okay Wow you know exactly and he is
welcome here I want to let you know
something we go outside because I gotta
let you know the first 10 chance I get
I'm in a jump shape and jump join the
Rebel Alliance and again it doesn't
really land on Luke if he eats all he
wants to do is get out of the house
right it doesn't matter to him whether
it's the rebels or whether it's the
Empire so you think he could have been
turned a completely different way
absolutely well I need to exactly and
the thing is to me that's character I
mean it's interesting it's in the novel
by Alan Dean Foster
so even Mark Hamill said that Luke would
have totally gone evil it's left his own
decisions in that moment but obi-wan
Kenobi had been keeping a very watchful
eye on him in case anybody came for him
from the Empire or if he himself found
the dark side of the force just sort of
babysitting him in a way that raised did
not have like there was no obi-wan
Kenobi watching her grow up
so there's actually another Star Wars
comic book when they were still at Dark
Horse
that explored this line of thought it
was sort of like the what-if version of
Star Wars where Darth Vader learns the
truth about Leia early goes to her and
turns her to the dark side so that by
the time you get to that final fight
during Return of the Jedi where Vader
turns against the Emperor it's actually
the Emperor pitting Luke against Leia
and that provides the impetus for Darth
Vader to turn against the Emperor so it
still ends in a similar way but it just
shows you how open these younger
characters like Luke's Leia and now Rey
are open to persuasion so all it takes
is the right moment to push them over
the edge that makes them do something
that crosses the line in there's kind of
a moment like that during Star Wars
Episode 7 between Rey and kylo Ren
during their big fight where rageous
lashes out with complete emotion so
number 3 I'll play this JJ Abrams clip
where he basically explains Ray's crazy
intensity during this fight
the first time you saw this it was just
like good defeating evil very simple
idea but JJ Abrams commentary sort of
recontextualizes this so here's this
clip I also showed this film entirely
cut to uh my friend Ava Duvernay and she
had a bunch of great suggestions one of
them was that she really wanted to see
Daisy in her attack on when coming up
that's one really cool moment I'll show
you the shot that ended up getting her
her suggestion but we always had this
moment when we shot of the original ring
and this used to be where she calls him
a monster and then pushed back but
instead we reshot this and had her take
this moment of hearing the force and
thinking about what Maz had told her
about closing her eyes letting it in and
so she has this incredibly internal
moment that is sort of extended in kind
of movie time where she basically feels
it accepts it and it's now ready to kick
his ass
so here's the shot that we got from the
reshoots
this one here ready and back Oh a little
thing but it really connects you to her
intensity so ray is totally capable of
lashing out just like kylo Ren lashes
out having that force tantrum when he
gets all the bad news earlier in the
film so number two I know a lot of
people have different theories about
Rey's heritage
some people think she might even flow
from Emperor Palpatine or Snoke himself
like she literally flows from evil but
on the simplest level she is going to be
touched by the dark side of the force if
she hasn't already it seems like she has
just a little bit just because of the
way they're recontextualizing the force
in these new movies so part of the drama
of the rest of this story is going to be
watching how she deals with that like
those emotions the dark side of the
force the choices that she makes
along with kylo Ren we talked a lot
about kylo ren's motivation the path
that he's on but the exact same thing is
happening to Rey in one of the greatest
things I think that these new movies are
doing is not oversimplifying things it's
not just good versus evil it's not red
lightsaber versus green lightsaber gray
Jedi are a better example Jedi's it
walked the line between the dark and the
light side of the force just in the
context of the film qui-gon jinn is a
good example of someone who was like a
great Jedi someone who tried to take a
more balanced approach to the force than
the Jedi Order was comfortable with so
number one Luke himself went to aux to
this planet that he's on at the end
looking for the original Jedi Temple
they haven't fully explained what's
going on that backstory they imply a lot
of things but it sounds like the Jedi
had started to misinterpret the true
spirit of the force a long time ago so
the Jedi Anakin rebelled against were
wrong but so was Anakin in the Emperor
and there's a deeper truth about the
force that both Luke Skywalker and Snoke
in these new films are trying to reveal
in their own way obviously Snoke is a
little bit more of an antagonist so he's
trying to create this super Jedi from a
fallen life-sized Jedi even though the
movies typically have often
endings that doesn't mean that everyone
always does the right thing makes the
right choice doesn't go down the dark
side for at least a little while so robe
one was a really great example of that
about how the good guys do very terrible
things to further their cause so that's
going to be Rey and kylo Ren in the new
film so let me know in the comments how
do you think that Rey is going to be
tempted by the dark side of the force in
Episode eight congratulations to this
week's Star Wars giveaway winner Kaden
un-to imax gift certificates just
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll just announce
the winner when I post my next Star Wars
video so if you want to leave a request
for a Star Wars video just put it in the
comment I'll be posting some more
Deadpool 2x4 later tonight then we get
some Game of Thrones some more comic
book stuff happening this weekend it's
going to be awesome well you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
the episode 8 kylo Ren teaser and you
can click here for the Justice League
Green Lantern Corps teaser thank you so
much for watching everybody what's that
bot I'll see you guys tonight
me me me me me me me
[Music]
you